second attempt
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they have been brilliant on third down
so far today
mahomes lofting it down the middle
Reggie Davis of 34 yard strike
itself it's the football
homes taking a shot
touchdown
going right for the jugular
you come from the side
[Applause]
Wow nice move first down textile tantric
Mahone's a 16-yard and that's what this
team would have missed if he didn't fly
tonight second attempt
[Applause]
golden the 3dr the motion now we stop
[Music]
home on the keeper makes one miss now a
little pop pass to socket and then
connects for the second touchdown
[Applause]
let's get to it more they practice it to
boil the light the homes out of the
pocket
[Applause]
but this throw by my home stepping to
his left and just literally winging it
watch where it drops right in the
breadbasket here now eyes you know first
we're gonna stick up for the defensive
guy home the Holmes looks
he keeps it
[Applause]
well tortillas are flying and I'm not
sure you know that you like that a
cyclops 37
[Music]
[Applause]
there is simply no defense for Patrick
mahomes to do he still gets away from
pressure he loses the eyes never stopped
you've seen the feel from his review
point when up at you boy Adam left coach
you like that concept I know you like
that content hit subscribe for more of
it from Bleacher cool